okay so we got the blind bandit and how
cool is that we got a new cast member on
the team so that's uh that's pretty
awesome and the episode is pretty
straightforward it's pretty much
establishing this character um who is
blind but can still get around very well
because of the earthbending and I like I
like episodes like this where somebody
has an obvious disadvantage whether they
be blind or deaf or they're missing a
limb or they can't water there's
something like that and they overcome it
regardless
uh but what the more popular one seems
to be blind because I do think of why I
think of daredevil I think of quest for
Camelot I think of you know sort of the
the blind warrior seems to be a very
popular one to do probably because
anyone can identify with oh if you can't
see you would automatically assume oh
well that person's gonna have a really
really tough time uh then probably even
tougher than if you can't hear or can't
smell or what or whatever assesses you
want throw in there or you know or
losing a limb and so on so forth so the
blind seems to be very popular one uh
but what I like that this one does now
compared to something like quest for
Camelot I'm sure there's other examples
of this like in terms of like a bad
example for how it's not done well
because in quest for Camelot
II can't believe I'm making that compare
so it's only what's going to my mind I
know I've see it elsewhere the blind
person is so good at what they do you
sort of question whether or not they're
blind you know why I think only once or
twice do you see him wave the stick
around as if he can't see but other than
that if no one ever told you he was
blind you wouldn't even connect that he
was blind uh be here that sparking sound
that's my bed sorry um so what I like
about this is that actually gives an
explanation of how she can accommodate
for this that the earthbending she's so
good at earthbending that she can
actually sense where people are where
things
are and the blindness actually helps
advance her earthbending skill so they
feed into each other I thought that was
very smart um and a lot of these other I
think like daredevil you know does
explain how he can see better and such
but I really like how they do give an
explanation cuz I have seen other
examples they're not coming to my head
but I have seen other examples where
they make them blind but it's almost
pointless because they're so good at not
being blind
you know and I've known blind people and
I mean I've seen them do stuff that you
just won normally think of blind person
can do it but they're still blind so I
really like the fact that they do
account for that for example at the end
I think Sokka throws the belt at her and
because it's not on the ground she
doesn't see it in it or on the head you
know that's and that's okay because
obviously she accommodates for that in
up in Chile another way she's like the
best earthbenders on the show so uh so
that's good I like to see I guess here
we go with the character because as of
now it's it's not a bad character but I
mean so far it's just one episode in but
I don't see her as good as say Katara or
soccer or Zuko or Azula uh so I'd like
to see what they do with her because
right now it's they obviously got her
backstory and that she's a little
resistant to wanting to leave she
doesn't know much else but at the same
time she does want to see the world she
wants to Earthbend and she does finally
break her father's wishes um but I'm
curious to see what other characters are
gonna develop with this because I'm
saying to myself there's got to be more
than this if they're gonna make her like
a permanent cast member so I get the
feeling they will they'll develop a
pretty good character with her uh I love
the wrestling aspect of this it's
obvious they're satirizing wrestlers
again great thing about this world that
we've if you don't know wrestler is this
you can just see it as a form of
entertainment like gladiators and such
and so I I really like that it works
both ways
uh socco's are turning into a
traditional wrestling fan you
Buie who's supposed to be food and
shearing whose of us be cheered and I
get good comedy from him I love when
they get the ransom note from the
boulder and he's so happy because he has
the boulders autograph I mean that
that's very funny
um the boulder I love I love this guy
always refers to a bull do is not
pleased he's are like Duffman he reminds
me a lot of that uh what else what else
a pretty straightforward episode just
establishing a new character to come on
board I say the one thing maybe I didn't
like which I guess it sort of depends
where it goes I'm usually not a fan of
when a good person has a
misunderstanding so they're gonna do
something bad because of it something
about that just always seems boring
maybe because I know it's gonna end up
with that person realizing oh wait I
should have listened or oh wait I
shouldn't have jumped to conclusions but
it's also sort of uh the girl's fault
too uh you know cuz she said I had dad
said it's fine it doesn't she think any
consequences gonna come of this so so
there's this other chase going on
between these two people were gonna try
and hunt them down and from the sound of
it it sounds like it wouldn't like it
but then again the show does surprise me
it does throw me for loops I'm not
expecting and certain plot twists I
think I'm not gonna like or I think
we're gonna be predictable again they
throw me for a surprise so hopefully
that'll be the case here cuz just from
the set up I'm so going yeah I I hope
that's good
I hope they do something good with that
so it sounds like the wizard hey I
remember when the well is that the
father and the brother had to go find it
but then that other guy who's supposed
to catch the kids is going after them
and stuff it's like I I just don't care
for those kind of plots you know just
that the bad guys chasing after them
over sort of a dumb misunderstanding so
maybe they'll do something go with it
maybe they'll do something either
legitimately funny or legitimately heavy
so I don't know just from the set up
it's not sound like much but I could be
wrong like I said show surprises me a
lot so uh yeah not too much else on this
one I guess I think the only word joke
ever we stood out to me I thought was
really funny was I liked Katara
talking to the boys trying to get
information Jesus how you know girl has
her ways and stuff and they're frozen uh
the head to head along the the walls
there I just I think that's a funny
visual it's like such a strange way to
get in from each and at the very
creative way so I like that and actually
when I saw it I did legitimate ly think
they're gonna go for the Oh is she like
sweet talk number so I like that she
kicked their ass I thought that was
funny
um Oh God and when uh when when she says
like you know I got my eye on you and
sock it just goes what was it just like
what a sure that that killed me I a joke
like that should not make me laugh cuz
that's such a like a you know aside
there's something like that but it was
so funny oh it's it's sucking me in more
and more with its humor like I said the
humor started off and just got so good
um so I'm really loving it uh yeah
that's about it just a very basic
introduction of a new character
hopefully it's a good character looks
like you'll be a good character and yeah
just seeing the next one